un viaje ya considerado como histórico
del presidente ucraniano boladimir
zelenski a Bruselas ha servido sobre
todo para enviar el importante mensaje
de que el destino entre la Unión Europea
y Ucrania están Unidos y que
inevitablemente una victoria ucraniana
es también una victoria europea más aún
cuando Ucrania después de la Victoria
forme parte del club comunitario Este ha
sido el principal mensaje de celenskin
que también se ha dirigido ante el pleno
del parlamento europeo lleno
absolutamente todo el pleno para hablar
de estos valores comunes entre Ucrania y
la Unión Europea más decidido zelens que
ha hablado ante los líderes europeos o
los que ha pedido más decisión
pragmatismo es decir armas porque sin
ellas no habrá Victoria para Ucrania y
sobre todo porque cree que es importante
para su ejército para llevarlo a la
victoria también ha asegurado que ha
visto señales positivas entre los
líderes europeos pero que espera que
estas señales positivas se conviertan en
pasos con créditos y también en
respuestas decididas por parte de las
capitales europeas también ha hablado de
la adhesión zelenski ha vuelto a
reiterar su decisión de que a finales de
este año empiecen las negociaciones para
que el país pueda entrar en el futuro
dentro de la Unión Europea desde
Bruselas se ha recordado que la decisión
requiere unanimidad pero aún así los
líderes de las instituciones han
valorado los grandes esfuerzos que ha
hecho Ucrania incluso a pesar de estar
en guerra hoy celest que sobre todo ha
querido hacer un mensaje menos
beligerante sobre todo de discursos
menos beligerantes pero sobre todo
quiere Mostrar el líder que es capaz de
ser cuando un día en el futuro pueda
estar aquí reunido en este mismo
edificio con sus homólogos europeos